everybody ready one two three we're
gonna lay the balloon in the basket that
way so you can do the suit up right here
many years have led up to the flying
that we're doing now I don't think I've
ever looked forward to anything more
than this
Trent I guess you're taking care of fuel
thanks now I get to put all of this time
and all of this energy into the ultimate
adventure which is flight
[Music]
[Music]
I get to have the history of space and
flying exploration and I get to do it in
a spacesuit that I have built okay you
can hand me the pressure force if this
is hard for me to beat as a life
experience
thank you reading but so we're gonna put
my helmet on and pressurize and go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my name is Cameron Smith I'm an
archaeology professor at Portland State
University and for the past eight years
I've been building my own space suit
when I was 12 my dad would bring home
eight millimeter footage from the moon
landings and he project them on the
bedroom wall and I would watch these
alien scenes that was a pretty magical
thing to me a lot of it was about
something new a lot of it was about
exploration seeing something that hadn't
been seen before between the ages of 10
and 14 I wrote to all of the Apollo
astronauts and I was trying to get into
space I wanted to know how they told me
to fly for the military but my eyes
weren't perfect so that was the end of
that dream when I was very young for a
long time I thought if I were just a
little smarter if I could be more
resourceful then I really did think I
could go to space so I thought the way
that I could get there was to build a
balloon and to make my own spacesuit
for the human body space is a very
difficult place in the shade it can be
minus 300 Fahrenheit in the sunshine it
can be plus 300 Fahrenheit that's hard
to imagine for all these reasons if
you're going into space you'd be
well-advised to wear a spacesuit a
spacesuit is basically a compression
device it holds you together in the
absence of atmospheric pressure it has
some properties that are going to keep
you warm but it also doesn't keep you to
warm it has to be gas impermeable it
should be flame proof so it can't catch
fire you're dealing with fuels of all
kinds and it also has to be non-stretch
that is you don't want it to be
ballooning up when the suit is
pressurized it's a fascinating challenge
to get all of those things functioning
in one garment alright first first
pressurization attempt with the newly
reinstalled appendix alright so this is
a test keeping the fire extinguisher
built for a new high
[Music]
it sounds mind boggler how do you build
a spacesuit well I started looking at
the history of early pressure suits in
the 1930s people were trying to fly to
high altitudes in balloons and when I
read their stories and I learned exactly
how they built those suits and I learned
that they flew two fifty and sixty
thousand feet and most of them survived
I thought surely if they could do that
with pink skin and leather and rubber I
can use today's materials and do the
same thing the basic spacesuit to get
you to orbit and back has been on the
order of a hundred thousand dollars and
weighing almost 75 pounds my goal has
been one thousand dollars five kilos or
about eleven pounds and to reach 63
thousand feet above the surface of the
earth at that altitude the only thing
that will keep me alive in my balloon
flights is my spacesuit
[Music]
when I started all this I used the
cheapest and most available things
possible to prove the design so for
example for the neck ring for the helmet
I was using a pie tin I've used Commons
plumbing ball valves motorcycle
batteries aquarium pumps zip ties
tremendous basically I'm trying to mount
this valve on the sides it's not gonna
flop around the least interesting way to
have done this would be to buy a Russian
spacesuit on ebay you can do that but
that's not fun it's not interesting to
just copy what somebody else has done
I wanted to reinvent the wheel myself so
we will be able to read suit pressure
which will not come up high the margins
for air on this project are very slim
and you need to be willing to work at
this through failure after failure I
have failed and then rebuilt the thing
and that failed and I rebuilt it and
that failed sometimes I was trying to
fix a technical problem for a couple of
years but then I would say I'm not gonna
get beaten by this and try again
[Music]
[Applause]
okay I'm gonna start going through fear
they're setup checklist just to be sure
we have all the items so we're looking
at crew gloves and those are in the
orange case five six seven eight we have
our pin keepers these are flying
instruments if we can put these up high
somewhere that they're not being crushed
I have to run this like a small space
program and I have to have every
checklist item theoretically known
practically understood practiced
simulated many times and then I have to
fulfill that sequence perfectly during
the flight and I know that somewhere
deep in the the labyrinth of the system
some little mistake could kill me that's
a great challenge if I wanted to do
something easy I would I would pick
something easy but that doesn't interest
me
the difficulty intrigues me and is a
source of vitality for my life this is
all the paperwork required to fly a
balloon somebody asked me one time if
this was a suicide mission I thought
that was rather stupid if this is a
suicide mission it is the most expensive
and longest suicide in history it's
eight years and all my time and energy
and passion so this is a very bad way to
kill yourself
I think we've now succeeded at building
the thousand dollar spacesuit nobody
will believe me of course until I test
it and prove it in in space conditions
and it can work it can work because
there's no wind I'd like to kind of go
dead center of the playa and then we'll
set everything up and no matter which
way the wind is going we've got yeah
okay any questions great thanks guys we
got to pull the sides out watch your
head
[Music]
okay we can prepare the seals Sun is
coming up now
nice and high okay very good
[Music]
okay it all looks nice and squared away
we should launch we got a pill 46
just like when I was a kid and dad
projected these Apollo landing films now
I'm flying a balloon and when I'm
wearing this suit and doing that well
that's pretty special for me
these are childhood dreams come true
[Music]
everything's good suits one psi I know
that there'll be a moment on the highest
flight where I realize I've done what I
wanted to do and everything works and it
might only be ten seconds in your life
ouch 10 1000 feet I really believe that
when I get to the very high altitude and
my suit is functioning and the
temperature is right and my Timoner
reads 60,000 feet I know that that 10
seconds is going to be great and it's
going to be a treasure that I can bring
home and I can live off that for years
no matter what calamity comes along
doesn't matter I will be able to live on
that ten seconds of experience maybe for
the rest of my life
that will make everything worth it
[Music]
you
you